who are you going to call
not them 9-1-1 let's talk about it
what's your emergency i think i hear a
baby crying in the wall how's the baby
on the wall no no not on the wall in the
wall there's a baby inside my wall
what 12 seconds later
i thought that's just a joke we did as
medical students listening to the wall
to hear the other room with the
stethoscope oh my god
[Music]
a premature baby that cries loudly
enough that you can hear it through a
wall and a pipe and it's surviving
through water i mean like this is
ridiculous
all right what's up
get the head out bob you get the head on
you got to push them below this is not
how i've delivered babies when i
delivered babies not from pipes
so much wrong with this
okay pull her out pull up fake baby too
all right she's never been starting cpr
come on correct form with the hands but
gotta push a little deeper man this is
such a ridiculous scene that i would say
this would never happen but i know one
of you is gonna pull out an article
where one person in some small rural
area this happened to and they survived
and you guys gonna see mike you don't
know what you're talking about as a
doctor
your daughter just had a baby we have to
get her to the hospital it was that the
mother no screw her
she's a child that's ridiculous you
don't get to play judge and jury you
gotta save everyone's life especially
when it comes to a child who's lost a
lot of blood who knows if she's in her
right state of mind if this baby dies
it's on you why would the baby die and
why is it on her what does she have to
do with anything who's choking you do
you know him
oh
that's a boa snake fans help me out here
that's a problem um yes call for help
bobby it's no use that thing is like 10
feet long and constriction strength is
like 50 pounds per square inch
everyone is doctor house
crap it's getting really tight
i think we're gonna have to put it down
okay stand back
[Music]
yeah well it was him or you in a
facebook situation like that
i always choose to save the more
attractive one
i hope he gets fired after a statement
like that would you ever speak to a
patient that would not
respectfully what's your emergency
we're not on the beach we're on the
freeway what
[Music]
this show is so incredible
what the hell tiger shark we were
transporting her for release into the
wild trump
the truck jackknifed and how did the
guy's arm end up inside the shark
someone needs to explain that to me can
we wait that long or just no no don't
kill her she's come so far gosh
award for empathy goes to that gentleman
he's getting his arm
literally torn off and he's like think
about the shark
all right let's get it transported now
nice and easy
from a brachial artery laceration you
can die in seconds how deep is that
yeah it's full arm it's the whole thing
and behold the salabasana
everything hurts
the baby is he okay check your baby
right now okay i'm gonna touch you right
here in your stomach okay there's no
trauma to the abdomen why would there be
trauma to the abdomen she's doing yoga
easy i'm gonna take you
all right i'm gonna take care of that
you take care of this i got you i got
you i think i'm having contractions are
they real contractions though all right
what's your name
okay i need a cup of water for beth am i
in labor i think it's braxton hicks
i mean braxton hicks contractions are
something reasonable to think about how
he knew that instantly without
understanding if she's totally in labor
or not i have no idea that's kind of
ridiculous you get you nice and relaxed
and hydrated okay there's just like
really good questions to be asked here
not are you thirsty
oh my god my water broke
what is this class i don't know what's
your emergency my son he hit his head on
the diving board and he's not breathing
oh my god he's turning blue i need you
to perform cpr on him interesting that
they'd say to perform cpr right away i
would like to check for a pulse first
but if he's turning blue that probably
means he's not breathing he's pulseless
he's not unresponsive again chest
compression chest compression chest
compressions it's not about mouth to
mouth anymore it's about pumping the
heart and causing it to push the blood
throughout your system which still has
some oxygen in it running around coming
around starting compressions i mean i
would have loved to see them check for a
pulse here is underwater i don't know
those are terrible chest compressions
they have to be at least two inches deep
you have to risk breaking ribs in order
for them to be effective remember the
job of the chest compressions is to
actually compress the heart and if
you're just doing them superficially
you're just doing it for a show
they are doing it for a show i guess
that's okay as soon as help arrives
most people just hang up
yeah
what are you sad okay okay
that's a no-no never point anything with
gun
at yourself nail gun paintball gun cap
gun
gun gun
he needs a level one trauma surgeon stat
i don't know what i'm supposed to do
don't pull it out
no do not remove the nail
help is on the way i'm gonna clear your
shirt so we can see what we're working
with dude do not clear anything put him
on the stretcher and bring him to the
hospital where emergency surgery can
happen you hit the bullseye
who makes jokes like that
hit the bullseye nice and easy bring it
around sure careful if you hit a lung
he's also going to have a collapsed lung
there as well take a few deep breaths
from me
bro just put him on the stretcher bring
him to the hospital stop stop torturing
the man i need to get you to the
hospital for pericardiocentesis that's
where they'll drain the fluid dude you
don't even know what is the extent of
the damage this is ridiculous that
they're diagnosing him already knowing
everything that's happening do you know
why i'm getting so angry because too
often patients come in and someone does
this like incorrect diagnosis thing on
the go and then i have to come in and
correct all this misinformation and it
confuses patients it's hard enough to
hear what's happening here when you have
a nail gun in your heart but then
imagine trying to deal with who's right
who's wrong
of course i did why
that is not a good rhythm
[Music]
yep that's a problem that is a problem
but only if he's not dead
in this case there's nothing you can do
the only thing you can do is try and
resuscitate but like pulling the nail
out pushing the nail further in you're
only gonna do more damage come on you're
not leaving your daughter hanging like
that
we got a pulse
[Music]
yep
heart's beating again yeah hearts
beating again but he's actively bleeding
out there's like zero use for
celebrating here it's quite often that a
patient gets resuscitated with cpr only
to lose their pulse shortly thereafter
so like this is not a win by any means i
can't move my neck oh no
is that is that a phineas gage situation
right now got a piece of rebar through
his skull how is that even possible well
it's possible brain tissue has no nose
receptors it can't feel pain that is
actually true however the meninges feel
pain skin feels pain and you know all
those videos circulating around with the
person playing an instrument while
they're doing brain surgery that can
happen because the brain has no pain
receptors what what why why aren't you
guys like cutting me out of here it's
complicated
why you've been injured jim well how bad
is it it's not good
what what is this conversation thing
that happens this is not real just do
your job you're 9-1-1 don't start taking
selfies and facetiming your friends
oh my god
we all kept trying to tell him to get it
fixed
she couldn't have unplugged it why the
hell didn't he just get out he might
have had a stroke how did he know he has
a stroke i mean these guys with their
like house md ridiculous diagnosis we
too may have had a stroke drugs could be
an underlying cause what was he on
what is this guy he's on drugs how do
you know look at him what do you mean
look at him
starting compressions
good compressions
yeah that's normal so keep going i mean
not normal but normal if your skin's so
damaged but the chest compressions
override that because remember when
someone's heart stops that means they're
dead so whether or not you damage their
skin they're already dead try and bring
them back nope he's gone i mean nope
he's gone do more chest compressions try
and bring him back my hands got dirty
he's gone i'm getting mad at the show we
have a stunt
so daring a video so bold it might just
break the internet oh my god is this a
youtube challenge a tick tock challenge
[Music]
what is the purpose of this how is the
bike not moving
how long has that poor guy been on there
he's probably like completely out of
here hey can you hear me
oh oh
that's a problem need an ophthalmology
consult stat it could be g-lock g-force
poisoning from the force of the spin
right now all this blood is pulling
inside his head he's pressing against
his brain which is why he's out cold i
don't know if that's g-lock g-lock is
when you essentially have your blood go
to the lower part of your body and
you're not getting enough circulation
and this is a very big problem for f-16
pilots actually flew in f-16 so i
studied this click the video down below
i would not do this without an
ophthalmologist on site i would not do
this like there's no way firefighters or
first responders would do this
[Music]
wow that was
super eventually could you die from
spinning that much i mean you could die
from anything like can you run to your
death yeah
speaking of g-forces check out this
video of me flying in f-16 that's right
i experienced 9.2 g's check it out and
as always stay happy and healthy but
really check this out
[Music]